take some of the best mexican food in
town and add a little uptown funk and
you have latin eye presented by bruno
mars's silvari rum at el dorado cantina
and here to tell us more is their
director of operations ryan claussen and
mixologist omar francesca welcome you
too thank you so much for having us this
segment is sponsored by el dorado
cantina and we are so excited to have
you guys here because number one the
food is superb but now you guys have a
latin night to talk about what's going
on um live night starts tomorrow night a
while back our principals who are very
close with bruno's camp
had brought him into the restaurant he
tried the food some of the favorites the
lobster tacos the guacamole the pizzole
loved everything we had a great time
together i started talking about salva
ray rum which we're huge fans of already
figured out how to put two and two
together and
came up with this latin night concept
that's launching tomorrow night so tell
us what is going to happen at latin
night we will have live music we'll have
djs we'll have bottle service we'll have
small bites available out on the patio
you can reserve tables at 702-333-1112
it's going to be a blast we're going to
have a great time a lot of energy a lot
of fun a lot of great stuff yeah this is
the rum so there's there looks to be
three different varieties here omar can
you tell me a little bit about
absolutely so silver ray is a panamanian
rum uh from uh single state so
everything all the raw ingredients in
the water is derived from the same
estate
it is a five-year-old rum the coconut
expression is macerated with coconut and
the chocolate of course with chocolate
and then they have that yellow box over
there is the owner's reserve which is a
blend of 15 to 25 year old rums so it's
a
good stuff and you're you're creating
some exciting drinks here and they're
all named after some of bruno mars songs
exactly exactly so let's talk about
something so we have a we have a few so
this one is uh called locked out of
heaven is a twist on a mojito it's a
guava and coconut okay do you use the
coconut one yeah so we use the coconut
and the white rum in this one so it's uh
it's fruity refreshing a little bit of a
hint of coconut with predominantly guava
flavor profile at the front we have the
coffee break which is a twist on
espresso martini it's liquor 43 infused
with coffee in house
a little bit of simple syrup fresh
espresso and we use the chocolate
expression as the base and then over the
top we have a little bit of abuelita
chocolate to keep it uh concise with uh
with the concept of mexican concept and
it's just garnish with the viola and
some some coffee beans i am so excited
about this what's the other one so this
one right here is called 24 karat magic
it's a it's a tea syrup a little bit of
caramelized pineapple puree
the white expression of the rum and it's
topped off with toppo chico
i've always wondered about topo chico
like that's
a mineral water that goes in this right
yeah so chico was acquired by coke a few
years ago it was uh originally a mexican
company and it's a real uh mineral water
okay i want to taste one while we taste
what do you guys think ryan do you think
bruno mars is going to stop by
oh i want to taste the drink oh yeah
absolutely
yes
okay do you think
always a chance he did mention when on
his visit that if he is in town he would
love to come by and even said that he
would love to get on stage and play
drums with the bands oh you got to check
it out if you want to go experience
latin night this is the place to be you
never know who you're going to run into
and these drinks omar this is fantastic
thank you thank you so much
i'm not giving this one back we're
locked out of heaven thank you
you can check it out every thursday from
9 pm to 1am featuring salvari cocktails
and live music from puerto vicente space
to to get reservations and info you can
call 702-333-1112
kendall over to you by the end